what will it be like to look up there
and see your child holding them it's
gonna be surreal yeah I mean I'm so
excited like she she's always been at
home texting me watching you in the
Globes when we've been here before and
now she's gonna be on this stage and
just like so proud of it like right how
excited are you and did you do it was
there any special advice your dad had
for you it's very exciting I mean it was
just all I guess you know presents
advice you know hold your present hold
your presents how to swag that stage of
swag Coachella you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna DJ at Coachella and I find
it fascinating everybody doesn't know
that you're a DJ catching some heat like
oh he's a DJ now but I've been DJ since
I was 14
but Coachella is like a lifetime dream
for any deep any DJ I'm so excited to do
it I can't wait can't wait is there any
shot and you just tell me James Bond
James Bond how much of you is over no no
no it's the biggest rumor in the world
you know that I know it's a rule but
listen if somebody would fit I've seen
lots of people online or saying this
should be the next James Bond I
appreciate it I mean it's a compliment
it's a compliment but I don't think
there's any it's not gonna happen just
putting out there see this tomorrow good
luck tonight are you ready
are you carrying anything from your
father or anybody
mr. face that was shade on daddy
wedding play yes we are this year this
year we can't wait we're excited a great
time at the Royal Wedding so will you I
mean will you take anything from that
you know what they did they had an
amazing time they surrounded themselves
with people that they loved and loved
them and that's what we want to do we're
just gonna have a great day yeah just
want to toast for a Cause she told oh
yeah she's yeah $1,000 you don't have to
drink thousand dollars there anything
you say any arm charity just toast - Oh
fantastic so I'm gonna toast to my
daughter's charity she's working with
our GP Henson on mental health and she's
used the Golden Globes to expose that so
here's to that should be proud of
[Music]
[Applause]